okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 a very exciting day in some
sense although I've not yet identified
how but people are blowing up the phone
lines let's see what's on people's minds
starting with our caller from the three
four seven area code caller from three
four seven what's your name and where
are you calling from today caller from
three four seven are you there hi I'm
Owen
yes you are that's me yes it is yes I'm
here this is Nick from calling from
Brooklyn hey Nick how's it going David
good hello yes your honor
yeah yeah right oh yeah just wanted to
call obviously huge fan of the show just
wanted to call in - yeah just wanted to
hear your opinion on about something so
I'm obviously we've been hearing a lot
about about Trump being compared to you
know say Hitler um which is obviously
not the case however you know kind of
looking into the history yes kind of
before World War Two as well as after
World War two I think you could make the
argument that kind of the ideologies at
the time maybe even today I kind of
closer line I'd say - the kind of to the
ideas of the Nazi Party then to possible
possibly kind of the USSR's communism
kind of that idea so kind of going into
kind of going into America first
movement in the thirties and forties as
well as denouncing Japanese as you know
less the lesser race time during the
Pacific campaign and then obviously
sheltering Nazi officials post-world War
two so just want to kind of hear your
opinion on that and how that maybe plays
into you know what's going on today yeah
I mean I think you're the we don't
really need to do the sort of hyperbolic
sensationalists thing of saying Trump is
like Hitler to have a conversation about
similarities in pre-world War two
Germany how Donald Trump Donald Trump's
tendencies so when you look at the use
of hyper nationalism to justify policy
when you look at the other ring of
certain groups that Donald Trump has
identified
Ben it's ranged it's been everything
from Mexicans with the whole many you
know rapists and all that stuff
Muslims from the Middle East Asian folks
in different ways when you look at the
sort of attitude towards media that
Donald Trump espouses and a free press
there are definite similarities so you
know when you look at somebody like
Timothy Snyder has written a lot about
this you don't have to say Trump is like
Hitler I have no reason to think right
now that Trump is you know looking to
exterminate Jews or any other particular
group and the way that Hitler wanted to
but there are many similarities between
what we see now and pre-world War two
Germany and it's perfectly reasonable to
talk about them signs of totalitarianism
authoritarianism right right and I think
just talking about your kind of
disbelief that that common communism or
socialism you know the big evil um going
back to the forties you know where was
the big evil compared to Iran kind of
cozying up to some of the Nazi beliefs
especially in in America I think it's
kind of a dangerous train of thought and
I can definitely see that still
happening today in terms of the way that
the right price kind of communism as
well as socialism not really knowing the
difference between them yes um yeah so
that's basically what I wanted to call
him already for context I I am I'm
German so I'm a u.s. bombed but raised
in Germany yes I was kind of an
interesting viewpoint on that but but
yeah thanks thanks for taking thanks for
taking my call and um all the best all
right great to hear from you Nick from
Brooklyn six 178 3-0 47 50 is of course
the number